first of all on the horrific events in
in Paris I think this is different from
some of the plots that we've seen here
in the UK from from from so-called
homegrown terrorists the Chancellor and
I had a briefing from mi5 and mi6 during
our meetings to get the latest
information that we could in terms of
how we respond obviously we will look at
everything that needs to be done the
Home Secretary will chair a Cobra
meeting tomorrow our level of alert is
already at severe we put it there in
August which means that we believe you
know an attack is highly likely there's
only one level higher than that and that
is to move it up to critical obviously
those levels are set by the Joint
Terrorism seson center they're not set
by politicians but we're already at a
very high level of alert I know the
Metropolitan Police and the intelligence
agencies will be looking very carefully
what's happened and see if there's
anything more that can be done here and
any more advice that can be given but
we're already on a very high state of
alert our security services do an extra
job they're working flat out already as
are the Metropolitan Police and other
police forces but there is no one single
answer to this these appalling
terrorists attacks we have to all be
vigilant we have to try to address all
the problems of radicalization that have
happened in our country we have to make
sure we invest in our security
intelligence agencies properly we have
to deal with the problems at source but
as we do all these things we must be
very clear about one thing which is we
should never give up the values that we
believe in and defend as part of our
democracy and civilization of believing
in a free press in freedom of expression
in the right of people to write and say
what they believe these are the things
that were defending we should be very
clear on this day that these values that
we have are not some sources of weakness
for us their sources of strength charger
and I were at the British Museum looking
at this extraordinary exhibition we're
also here contemplating how does Britain
how does Germany make a success
self in the years ahead and my argument
would be of course there are all sorts
of economic things we've got to get
right but as we do that the countries
that succeed in the future I think will
be those that stick to the values of
freedom of the probe of democracy of the
rule of law those are part of the things
that make our economies in our societies
in our political systems strong and
powerful and good and we mustn't give
those up so that's how I'd answer that
question you